at windsor castle last night she was on
sparkling form
and more than keeping up with those much
younger than her so the news that
doctors have told the queen to rest up
has come as a surprise her majesty is
said to have reluctantly taken their
advice and canceled a trip to northern
ireland
thank you very much i'm still alive nice
to see you again it's been five years
since she's been there and this was
going to be a significant visit with her
due to attend a service marking the
centenary of the partition of ireland
and the formation of northern ireland an
event already made controversial after
president of ireland said he wouldn't
attend
but even as monarch you have to listen
to doctor's orders if you are older and
that you've had an incredibly busy
schedule we do
think it is common sense and good advice
to say that we should try to rest and
recover because you would certainly be
more vulnerable to picking up minor
infections or perhaps having more
complications or difficulties with your
general health
since the 95 year old finished her
summer break in scotland she could not
have been busier first minister opening
the scottish and welsh parliaments
starting the commonwealth baton relay
it's good morning isn't it to you
speaking to new zealand's new governor
general and joined by princess anne at
westminster abbey the addition of a
walking stick an obvious sign of little
adjustments being made the palace told
me that the queen was going to be busy
this autumn and that was very much
guided by her wanting to be out and
about as much as possible because covid
cancelled so many engagements but there
will inevitably be some people who will
wonder whether or not she's been
overdoing it the fact the queen turned
down the oldie of the year award saying
you're only as old as you feel shows
exactly what she thinks about slowing
down
but resting up is probably a precaution
the palace and number 10 no doubt keen
she's fit enough to open cop 26 in a
couple of weeks an event she's already
shared her views on
and is no doubt determined not to be one
of those who doesn't show up rhiannon
mills sky news at windsor castle